こんにちは！　はじめしゃちょーです！
今日は２月の３日水曜日
豆まきの日でございま～す！
豆まきの日は…
まぁ、一般的な家庭では豆をまいたりですね
南南東…
ぇ、ほんとに南南東？
南南東
コンパス！！
ちくしょう…ｗｗ
はい、というわけで
今年は恵方巻を南南東の方向から食べるといいという感じでございます
一言も話さず南南東を向いて
恵方巻を食べきると
いいことがあるのかな？
という感じらしいんでございます
で、僕は思ったんすよ！
恵方巻を一言もしゃべらず一気に食うのはとても面倒くさい
時間もかかるんで
僕は面倒くさくてそんなことはしないんですよ
恵方巻を一瞬で食べる方法を思いついたので
その実際にその一瞬で食べる方法を今日は
実践していきたいと思います！
では行こう！
恵方巻が飛び散る可能性があります
恵方巻はちゃんと全部食べましょう
落ちてもいいように、ブルーシートを貼ります。
で、ここからなんですけども
少し準備するものがあります。
まずはこちら、恵方巻です。
まずは恵方巻を準備します。
この恵方巻をどのようにして一瞬で食うか
その方法なんですけども
今回はこちら、スリングショットです
パチンコですね
ここに物を置くと…こうやって伸ばして
こういう感じで
ものを一瞬で吹っ飛ばすことができるというものです
ここに恵方巻をセットして
こうやって、バコーンッ！とやると
ひゅんと一瞬で恵方巻が僕の口の中に入って、恵方巻が食べれるというわけでございます
よし！では、実際に恵方巻を一瞬で食ってみましょう！
では行こう！！
～♪
一瞬で僕の目の前まで恵方巻が来るので
僕はもう人間の反射的に
口を開けざるを得なくなります。
そこでもっかいしっかり口を開けて
恵方巻をパクッっと食って
一言も喋らず飯を食うので
願いが叶う
完璧だ
さぁ～来るがよい
恵方巻3つ準備してあるんで、チャンスは3回です
あ、ちょ、ま…
怖い…
え、まってまって、ちょ
母さんに怒られそうだな…
恵方巻飛ばすんじゃないよって言われそう
こい！
あ、まって！まって！
まって、ほんとに怖いそれ！
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
よし来い
$%&×〇☆◆！！！
惜しかったｗ惜しかったｗ
もう一回
いけそう…でも行けそうだよね
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
一発目粉々になってしまったので
2個目です！
顔狙えばいいから、顔
（いくよ？
まって
よしでは２発目いきまーす
こい！
ｳｳｳｳｳｳｳｳｳ☆
（わかった。これで重心をとらえればスピンしない。こう、ずれてると　ｼｭｩ…
あぁ、たしかにね
重心とらえればね、ただ具が出ちゃうから一発勝負だよ
はい！というわけで
２つの恵方巻はもう結構崩れちゃったので
次でラストです！
これで食べれなければ僕は今年、あんまり運がよくないかもしれません
では願いを込めて！ラスト恵方巻行きましょう！
いただきます！！
ﾊｧｧｯ!!
卵が出た、卵が出たぞ！
よし、口で
こい